en este vídeo quiero hacer un montón de
ejemplos de cómo factorizar un polinomio
de segundo grado que es también llamado
a veces una cuadrada una cuadrática a
veces un polinomio cuadrática una
cuadriga una expresión cuadrática pero
todo significa un polinomio de segundo
grado así que algo que vamos a vamos a
tener una variable elevada a la segunda
potencia en este caso en todos los
ejemplos van a ser la variable x así que
tenemos la expresión cuadrática x
cuadrada más 10 x + 9 ok y quiero quiero
factorizar lo en el producto de dos
binomios como hacemos eso bueno vamos a
pensar qué pasa si yo tengo digamos x +
a que multiplica a x + b donde hay b son
cualesquiera dos números sale entonces
qué pasa si yo multiplico esto bueno
tenemos ya un poquito de experiencia en
esto esto es x cuadrada luego x x b
v x + a por x x x + aporte más a x b o
si queremos agregar o sumar estos dos de
en medio porque tienen el mismo
coeficiente x podríamos escribirlo como
x cuadrada más además ve verdad que
multiplica x + a por b
entonces en general si suponemos que
este es el producto de dos binomios
veremos que el coeficiente de enmedio ok
este coeficiente de enmedio en el
término x digamos o digamos esto esto va
a ser la suma de ahí b ok debe ser la
suma de ahí b y el término constante va
a ser el producto de nuestro aire
entonces esto se relaciona con esto y
éste se relaciona con este y por
supuesto esto es lo mismo si con este x
cuadrada verdad así que como podríamos
utilizar esto para encontrar un ave que
cumplan que se puede factorizar es decir
a más b debe cumplir que es 10 y aporte
debe ser igual a 9
igual a 9 muy bien
ahora vencemos un poquito acerca de esto
cuáles son los factores de 9 ok es decir
2 números que multiplicados media 9
bueno pues tenemos que ver cómo se
factor iza el mismo 9 verdad vamos a
factorizar con números enteros así que
cuáles son los factores de 9 son 13 y 9
así que puede ser 3 por 3 no puede ser 1
por 9 verdad si es un 3 por 3 entonces
no tenemos que la suma sería 6 no sería
10 verdad pero si es 1 y 9 tendremos que
su suma 19 es igual a 10 así que se
funciona a podría ser 1 y b podría ser
igual a 9 así que podríamos factorizar
esto como un x + 1 por x + 9 x y si
multiplicas estos dos por supuesto
utilizando las habilidades que ya hemos
desarrollado en últimos vídeos podrás
ver qué es justamente este polinomio x
cuadrada más 10 x + 9
cuando ves algo así con los coeficientes
bueno cuando el coeficiente en el
término cuadrática es 1 o keith entonces
puedes pensar en dos números que sumados
te den el coeficiente en el término x y
que multiplicados te den el término
constante verdad en este caso tendría
que ser multiplicados 9 y sumados
tendrían que ser 10 esto sí está en su
forma estándar ok sí sí sí está en otra
forma bueno tendríamos que hacer algunos
ajustes pero bueno todo se reduce a ver
dos números que sumados me den el
término el coeficiente en x y que
multiplicados me den el término
constante vamos a hacer más ejemplos
para que esto tenga sentido vamos a
hacer x cuadrada más 10 x 10 x ya no
otro número digamos x 15 x más 50 vamos
a factorizar esto entonces es el mismo
asunto
tenemos un término x cuadrada y tenemos
un término de primer orden ok entonces
este debe ser la suma de dos números y
este de aquí el término constante debe
ser el producto de dos números así que
hay que pensar dos números que cuando
los multipliquen en 50 y sumados me den
15 y esto va a ser un poquito como un
arte para que hay que desarrollar y
necesitamos mucha práctica para que esto
venga
naturalmente entonces ahí ve quiénes
pueden ser vamos a poner que 50 puede
ser 1 por 50 2 por 25 de 4 no tendría
que ser 55 por 10 y creo que eso es todo
ok vamos a intentar con estos números y
ver si algunos de estos al sumarlos me
dan 15 digamos 1 y 50 multiplicados en
50 pero los sumados no dan 15 2 y 25 no
te dan
pero 5 y 10 5 y 10 eso suman 15 y
multiplicados nos dan 50 verdad entonces
si queremos factorizar esto podríamos
poner que es igual a x + 5 por x + 10 y
si luego multiplicas en verdad te
sugiero que lo hagas para que veas que
en efecto te da este polinomio de
segundo grado de hecho vamos a hacerlo
vamos a hacerlo esto es x cuadrada y x
por 10 son 10 x 5 x x es 5 x 5 x 10 son
50 ahora no tenemos que 5 x 10 nos da 55
x + 10 x nos da este término de medio
que justo es 10 x verdad perdón 15 x
muy bien entonces vamos a hacer vamos a
hacer algo distinto vamos a introducir
uno que otro signo negativo para ser más
interesante digamos x cuadrada menos 11
x más 24 es exactamente el mismo
principio necesito pensar dos números
que cuando lo sume me den menos 11 es
decir a más veces igual a menos 11 pero
que multiplicados a por b me den 24 que
debe ser esto igual a 24 ahora hay algo
que debes pensar aquí cuando multiplico
estos dos números estoy obteniendo un
número positivo estoy obteniendo más 24
eso significa que ambos números deben
ser positivos o ambos negativos verdad
es la única forma en que este producto
sea positivo ahora cuando lo sumo tengo
un número negativo si fuera positivo
bueno tendría que sumar dos números
positivos pero como la suma es negativa
entonces estos números tienen que ser
ambos
ahí ve son negativos verdad para que la
suma sea negativa recuerden uno no puede
ser negativo y el otro positivo porque
entonces el producto sería negativo y
aquí tenemos que es positivo entonces
tienen que tener el mismo signo y como
la suma es negativa entonces
forzosamente deben ser ambos negativos
así que pensemos cuáles son los factores
de 24 vamos a pensar digamos 1 por 24 1
por 24 2 por 11 y 8 por perdonara 11 era
3 por 8 4 por 6 ahora cuáles de estos
cuando los multiplico bueno 1 y 24 me
dan 24 2 por perdón no aquí no es 11
aquí es 12 así que sabemos que estos son
factores de 24 y que los dos al
multiplicarlos me dan justamente 24
verdad entonces
al sumarlos por supuesto deben dar menos
11 entonces pensemos aquí en el 3 y el 8
3 por 8 es igual a 24 y 3 más 8 es igual
a 11 ahora eso no funciona del todo
verdad porque queremos menos 11 pero qué
tal si hiciéramos ambos números
negativos es decir menos 3 x menos 8 es
igual a 24 y menos 3 menos 11
perdón entonces menos si le sumó menos 8
es igual a menos 11 y eso funciona muy
bien verdad entonces al factorizar esto
esto es x cuadrada menos 11 x más 24
será igual
x menos 3
x menos 8
vamos a hacer otro
uno que vamos a mezclar un poquito
digamos que tengo
x cuadrada
+ 5 x menos oh perdón 14 aquí tenemos
una situación diferente verdad del
producto de dos números es negativo
verdad a por b es menos 14 mi producto
es negativo eso me dice que uno de ellos
tiene que ser positivo y el otro
negativo y cuando hay sumo ambos números
me da cinco positivos verdad así que
pensemos en los factores otra vez de 14
que combinaciones de ellos cuando lo
sumo me da 5 y al multiplicar los menos
14 verdad ok entonces si tomo por
ejemplo el 1 y 14 sí tengo 1 por 14
digamos negativo uno menos 1 por 14 es
menos 14 pero menos uno más 14 es 13 y 1
por menos 14 es menos 13 así que no no
sé
- 1 déjame escribirlo bien esto es menos
114 es
13 y uno más menos 14 es menos 13 éstos
no funcionan porque no son iguales a 5
que tal 2 y 7 sí tengo menos 2
déjenme hacerlo con otro color si elijo
el menos dos más 7
esto es igual a 5 y estoy acabamos
verdad esto funciona digo intenté con
menos 2 y 7 que el producto es menos 14
y su suma me da 5 verdad muy bien
entonces ahí lo tienen esto va a ser x2
x x 7 esto está bastante lindo verdad me
menos dos más 75 y menos 2 x 7 es menos
vamos a hacer más ejemplos de estos
realmente quiero que tengan una
habilidad muy bien desarrollada para
esto digamos que tengo x cuadrada menos
x menos 56 así que el producto de estos
dos números tiene que ser menos 56 ok y
su diferencia porque uno tiene que ser
positivo y el otro negativo verdad la
diferencia tiene que ser menos 1 y en
los números que inmediatamente me votan
del cerebro esto ya lo he aprendido
varias veces es 8 por 7 me dan 56 bueno
también puede estar por ejemplo el 28
por 2 pero bueno realmente lo que quiero
es 8 y 7 porque su diferencia debe ser
cercano verdad tienen que ser cercanos
para que su diferencia sea uno es verdad
más bien menos uno ahora si su suma debe
ser menos 1 entonces al más grande hay
que ponerle el signo menos verdad para
que me queden negativo entonces menos 8
por 7 es menos 56 y menos ocho más 7 es
igual a menos 1 que es justo lo que
tenemos aquí justo este coeficiente así
que cuando lo factor hizo me queda x
menos 8 por x más 7 esto es algo un
poquito de los conceptos más difíciles
que uno puede encontrar en el álgebra
porque es todo un arte verdad tienes que
mirar los signos y las sumas y los
productos que cuando es positivo cuando
es negativo en fin mientras más práctica
tengas verás que esto sale más
naturalmente
ahora vamos a hacer vamos a cambiar un
poquito las cosas vamos a suponer que
tengo menos x cuadrada ok siempre hemos
tenido x cuadrada con el coeficiente
positivo verdad ahora vamos a tener
menos x cuadrada
digamos que tenemos menos 5 x más 24
como hacemos esto bueno la forma más
fácil desde que puedo pensar por ejemplo
es factorizar un menos uno entonces se
convierte en un problema como el
anterior digamos que esto es menos uno
por equis cuadrada más 5 x menos 24
verdad es simplemente factor hice un -1
puedes multiplicar el menos uno por todo
este polinomio y ver que es el original
o podría simplemente factorizar el menos
uno en fin esto es igual ahora esto es
el mismo juego que anteriormente verdad
necesito dos números que cuando se
multipliquen me dan menos 24 y así que
uno tiene que ser positivo y otro
negativo y ahora cuando tome su suma o
que realmente de su diferencia porque
son de signos contrarios debe ser cinco
así que pensemos en los factores de 24
ok 1 y 24
si es uno positivo y menos 24 es menos
23 si es al revés es menos 124 eso me da
eso no funciona digamos el 2 y el 12 si
es menos 2 con 12 me da 10 si es 2 con
menos 12 entonces tendría menos 10 que
aún no funciona digamos 3 y 8 sí tengo
menos en el 3 esto es menos 3 y 85 y eso
funciona si elegimos menos 3 y 8
esto funciona perfectamente porque menos
tres más ocho son cinco y menos tres por
ocho es menos 24 verdad así que esto va
a ser igual a menos uno que es el menos
uno que factor hice por x menos tres ok
qué multiplicada x + 8 es la
factorización de este polinomio en el
segundo grado después podría multiplicar
el menos uno por alguno de estos dos
factores puedes hacerlo puedes no
hacerlo no importa
hagamos uno más de estos mientras más
práctica y lo mejor yo creo así que
digamos que ahora tengo menos x cuadrada
más 18 x menos 72 así que otra vez
quiero factorizar el menos 1 verdad así
que esto es menos 1 por x cuadrada menos
18 x más 72 ahora tenemos que pensar en
dos números que cuando los multiplique
me da 72 y esto es positivo así que
deben tener el mismo signo y eso lo hace
mucho más fácil para pensarlo verdad así
que al multiplicar los 272 y al sumarlos
me da menos 18 así que tienen el mismo
signo y deben ser de signo negativo
ambos tienen signos
negativo y podríamos ir por todos los
factores de 72 pero bueno quizás no sé 8
por 9 no sé pero por ejemplo menos 8 y 9
eso es menos 17 verdad eso estaba muy
cerca déjenme mostrarles algo menos 8 -
menos 9 más menos 8 es menos 17 está
cerca pero no es exactamente así que
pensemos a lo mejor en 6 y 12 menos 6
más menos 12 eso es igual a menos 18 así
que como ven es todo un arte tienen que
tratar con todos los distintos factores
así que esto será menos 1 por x menos 6
por x menos 12